[APPLAUSE]
STEFANY SHAHEEN:
Thank you so much.
It's an honor to be
here at Google today,
and I'm very much
looking forward
to sharing our story with you
and answering some questions.
I'm especially proud to have
Elle and Coach with me today.
We've been on a book
tour for months now,
but Elle has the challenge of
being a junior in high school,
so getting her out and
having her be part of this
is a special day for us.
So I want to begin
by just sharing
some of the numbers,
because often,
when you hear about diabetes,
what you're hearing about
are the staggering numbers
you can see on the screen.
And we often forget
what the numbers
mean in terms of the human price
that is paid for people living
with a chronic disease.
So you've heard that the
rates of diabetes in America
are on the rise,
likely, and you've often
heard that the cost of caring
for long-term chronic disease
risks bankrupting our
health care system.
But what Elle, Coach, and I
are here to talk about today
is the personal price that
chronic disease can play.
And we're here to
share the unlikely way
we have found to cope with
the challenges of living
with a chronic disease.
I want to begin by giving
you some background about me,
because it will help
inform our story
and help you understand what
managing a type I diabetes
reality meant for a type A mom.
So this photo was
taken shortly after I
graduated from a master's
program at Harvard.
I got to the point at the
end of my time at Harvard
where I was so pregnant with
our fourth son, William,
who's the baby in
the photo, that I
couldn't fit behind a desk
and had to sit sideways.
And literally, the day after
I finished my last final
and completed the
program, William was born,
and I graduated
three weeks later.
And so I use this picture as an
example of my delusional state
that if I was willing to
work hard and pay attention
to detail and plan incessantly,
that I could make it all work,
that I could make work work
and school work and manage
four children under the age
of 8 at this point in time.
And I was able to hold on to
that illusion and delusion
for a while, actually.
About 11 months
later, we as a family
went up north to
the White Mountains
over Thanksgiving weekend.
And Elle had just turned
8 about two months
before this photo was taken.
And around August of that
year, so a few months
before Thanksgiving, we noticed
that she wasn't herself.
She seemed agitated,
moody at times.
We couldn't quite put our
finger on what was wrong,
but she wasn't her
enthusiastic, optimistic self.
And I knew it was too soon
for the dreaded puberty years.
She was only just 8.
There were some things
happening at school
with the transition
of a teacher,
and so I worried maybe
that was affecting her.
We couldn't quite
put our finger on it
until we were away together
as a family over Thanksgiving,
and her symptoms became so
acute that they were no longer
something we could
brush under the rug
or treat as if maybe this
was just something that she
was coping with emotionally.
So at this point, we just
celebrated Thanksgiving
with our extended family,
and we had headed up
with the six of us.
And the first
thing I noticed was
that after ice cream
for dessert one night,
she was especially thirsty--
couldn't quench her thirst,
drinking all the time.
And that night we were
in a small hotel room
and I heard her get
up multiple times
to go to the bathroom in the
middle of the night, which
also struck me as odd.
And then the next day,
there was an indoor pool
in the hotel where
we were staying,
and she put her bathing suit
on, and the bathing suit
that had fit her just
fine over the summer
was now too big, which it's
not supposed to go that way.
It's supposed to
go the other way.
And I thought, there's
something wrong.
And as you can see here,
her coloring was not good.
She had dark circles
under her eyes.
And I remember distinctly
walking down the stairs
to the lobby of this
hotel, because this
was before smartphones,
and Googling the signs
and symptoms of diabetes.
And my brother-in-law, my
husband's younger brother,
lives with type I diabetes, but
he was diagnosed as an adult.
And my husband and I were
together when he was diagnosed,
and I remembered vaguely what
symptoms he had described.
And so I started Googling
the signs and symptoms
on the only computer that
was in the hotel lobby
to see if I could come up
with some explanation that
would make me feel better about
what I was seeing in Elle.
Unfortunately, she
had every symptom.
She was excessively thirsty.
She was going to the
bathroom frequently.
She was irritable.
She had lost weight, clearly.
She seemed agitated.
And I said, well, you know,
let's just give it another day,
because then the next day, she
would wake up in the morning
and seem OK.
And it wasn't until later
this weekend, on our way home,
we stopped to get
a Christmas tree,
and she asked if she could
have some hot chocolate.
And she had some hot
chocolate, and couldn't make it
to the bathroom in time
before having an accident.
And that's when I knew
something was really wrong.
So the very next morning, we
were in her pediatrician's
office, and unfortunately, her
pediatrician was not there.
I begged the physician
assistant to do
what was a simple urinalysis in
the office, just a urine test.
And he did not know us.
We had never seen him before.
And he was dismissive, I
would say, kindly, and said,
well, you know, I think she's
probably just constipated.
She can't possibly
have type I diabetes.
I think let's just give
it another couple days
and see how she does.
And you have this
moment when you're
raised by two advocates--
my mom is a US senator.
My dad was a judge and a
lawyer while I was growing up.
I learned how to advocate for
myself and for my children.
And you always
have these moments
where you think, am I
just being too pushy?
Maybe I'm being too neurotic.
Maybe I'm being too type A.
Maybe I shouldn't insist.
But there was just
something that said
we just have to rule this out.
And so I said, well, I know
it's just a simple urine test.
Please just do the test.
And he left the
office and said, fine,
we'll do the test if it'll
make you feel better.
And within five minutes,
he had come back
into the office with his head
down and said, it's conclusive.
She has type I diabetes.
You have to go to Boston
Children's Hospital.
And by the time we got
to the emergency room
at Boston Children's
Hospital, the doctor who
attended and treated Elle said
if we had gone home that night
and she had woken up and
had a normal breakfast,
she would have ended
up in a diabetic coma
and would have been Medevaced
to Boston Children's instead
of taking her there
the night before.
So that really changed our life.
That was a point
at which I learned
very hard and fast
that even when
you work hard and
even when you are
willing to put as
much elbow grease
as you can muster into
whatever it is you're tackling,
life can throw you hurdles
that you just can't possibly
anticipate.
And I have to say
that at that moment,
I wasn't entirely
convinced that this
was going to be all that hard.
You don't really
know what you're
facing until you live with it.
And so for those of
you who don't know,
type I diabetes is an
autoimmune disease.
It means that Elle's body
does not produce any insulin.
And in this photo,
she's actually
showing her insulin
pump to Michael J.
Fox at an event where
they were both advocating
for stem-cell research.
Type I diabetes means that
you're constantly chasing
healthy blood sugar ranges.
Because your body is no
longer producing insulin,
you have to take it
in a synthetic form,
either in a shot or
in an insulin pump.
And you're constantly
making decisions
about how much insulin your body
needs, because your pancreas
isn't working.
So this means in Elle's case
that she tests her blood sugar
by pricking her finger
8 to 10 times a day
to make sure her blood
sugar is in a healthy range.
It means every time she
puts anything in her mouth,
she has to take either
a shot or tell the pump
that she needs insulin.
It means that everything
affects her day-to-day safety
and well-being-- so
exercise, stress, being
ready to take an exam at school,
can shoot her blood sugar high.
Playing outside in the cold
can drop her blood sugar low.
And low blood sugars
cause seizures, which
can ultimately lead to death.
And high blood sugars over
extended periods of time
can cause very complicating
factors and organ damage.
So getting this right,
for a type A mom,
became my singular focus.
And fortunately I have
this incredible inspiration
in the form of my
oldest daughter, Elle,
and she was willing to
jump in with both feet.
You know, there was this moment
at Boston Children's Hospital
where it was 2:30
in the morning,
it took us over 18 hours to
actually be admitted and given
a room, so for that 12 hours,
we were in a tiny emergency room
room where she
was lying on a cot
and there was no other
chair in the room.
And it was 2:30 in the morning.
We had finally gotten a room.
And I felt myself
slipping into that place
of despair, where you
start to self pity
and feel like, why me?
Why did this have to be us?
And then I saw Elle lying in
this bed feeling 100 times
better, because she finally
had insulin-- insulin she
needed that had been making
her sick for so long.
And I thought, well, I don't
have the luxury of going there.
There's no room for despair.
We've got to figure out
how to live with diabetes
and help Elle live her
best life with diabetes.
And that's really, for me,
where the journey began.
And I followed her lead from
diagnosis to we sit here today.
And I use this
picture because she,
from the very moment
of her diagnosis,
wanted to live out
loud with diabetes.
She wanted to tell
people about it.
She refused to be defined by it.
And she was willing to try
anything to deal with it.
So this was only about eight
months after diagnosis.
She was already trying
an insulin pump.
She, along with Michael J.
Fox and lots of other folks,
were advocating for
the stem-cell research
that we so desperately need to
ultimately cure the disease.
And that work actually led
her to the White House,
where she got to
be-- she was one
of the only children in the
room when President Obama signed
the executive order that
allows for stem-cell research.
Fast forward eight years,
and that stem-cell research
is at work right
here at Harvard,
and really the
researchers at Harvard
are on the precipice
of ultimately curing
type I diabetes as a result
of stem-cell research.
And I am 100%
confident we're going
to see that in her lifetime.
But we followed her lead as
she dove into medical research.
So within 28 days
of her diagnosis,
she was testing a drug therapy
at Yale New Haven Hospital,
where she was in the
hospital for a month going
through this process of
testing this new medication
over the course of two years.
And she was the first pediatric
patient at Mass General
Hospital to try the
bionic pancreas, which
is what you see here.
She's actually wearing four
continuous glucose monitors
that they were testing
across her stomach,
and the IV pole
she's attached to
has all the algorithms and
the intellectual engine
that is making the decision
for how much insulin
her body needed.
So while she was in the
hospital for four days
in order to test this, today,
just three years later, it
is now the size of
your smartphone,
and it's being
tested at diabetes
camps in Massachusetts.
And FDA is saying
that by 2017, we're
likely to see an approval
for the bionic pancreas,
or a version of it.
And so again, we
followed her lead.
The challenge is that
with type I diabetes,
it doesn't get easy.
It doesn't get any easier.
So even though she was willing
to try these drug trials
and she was trying
the insulin pump
the bionic pancreas,
every day pricking her
finger 8 to 10 times a day,
having to count
carbohydrate in everything
she puts in her
mouth-- she doesn't
have the latitude of
walking into the cafeteria
that we just walked through,
picking up something to eat
and just eating it.
It's a five-step process.
What am I going to eat?
How much carbohydrate's
in when I'm going to eat?
Am I coupling it
with any protein that
will slow the burn in my body?
How much insulin do I already
have working in my system?
What's my blood sugar right now?
All before she can take
a bite of anything.
So while she was 100% committed
to making life better,
the reality was that day to day,
this was a constant challenge.
And one of the ways
we found together
to cope with the challenge was
to stay invested and involved.
And so that's really what
led us to this unlikely hero
in our family, Coach.
We ended up co-chairing the
Juvenile Diabetes Research
Foundation Children's Congress,
which is an advocacy event
every two years in Washington,
and it brings 150 young people
from across the
country to DC to share
with new members of Congress
and current members of Congress
what it's like to live
with type I diabetes.
And we agreed to co-chair
this particular year
because one of the things that
we had discovered when Elle
tested the biologic pancreas was
that the regulatory environment
for approving these devices was
so unclear that industry was
saying they were no longer
going to be investing
in the advancements with
the bionic pancreas,
because the roadmap for
approval was very gray.
And so this particular
Congress was dedicated
to advocating with the FDA and
other agencies in Washington
to create a regulatory pathway
that industry could see
that would ultimately ensure if
all these boxes were checked,
we could get to a place
where the bionic pancreas
could be approved.
And again, I say this
because one of the challenges
is you live with risk
every day, right?
We're here at Google.
Google knows risk.
You have to take risk in
order to be successful.
And when you put
an insulin pump on
and it continues to
pump insulin even
when you have a low
blood sugar, that's
a risk we're living with.
And it's a risk in
many cases you're
willing to take because it
means you don't have to take
12 shots of insulin a day.
So Ellie right now is
wearing an insulin pump.
You can't see it.
It's wireless.
But it's going to continue
to pump insulin in her body
even if she doesn't need
it, because it doesn't know.
And so the bionic
pancreas brings
all this intellectual power,
and helps it understand, well,
if the blood sugar is dropping,
I'm going to shut the pump off.
Fighting the FDA to
help them understand
that this is how the technology
can work was a big challenge.
And it's what led us
to want to co-chair
the Children's Congress.
And it was at this
Children's Congress
that we saw a dog, a
golden retriever, who
was supporting a little girl.
At the time, I think
she was about 8.
She was younger than
Elle at the time.
And there were 150 children in
the well of the Senate hearing
room, and then another 200
proud parents watching.
And I sat and watched this dog
sit up and circle his person
multiple times and try to find
the parents of the young girl,
and then sit back down
because he couldn't
find them to make eye contact.
And then two minutes
later, he'd get back up
and he'd circle her again
until he could finally
get their attention.
And they came over
and tested her,
and sure enough, she
had a low blood sugar.
And we had heard about these
dogs because, as chairs,
we got to see the applicants
who wanted to come to Children's
Congress, and several of them
had talked about diabetes alert
dogs.
And you know, I've got my
Harvard degree and I think,
that's impossible.
I'm type A. I'm working so
hard to manage every day
and help keep Elle healthy,
and I can't figure it out,
and we've been into
all these trials.
How on earth is a dog
going to make this work?
So I went into this
event very skeptical.
I didn't think that there was
any way this really worked.
But if it provided some comfort,
then that was a good thing.
And then I saw firsthand
this dog alert his person,
and she had a low blood
sugar, and the parents
helped her treat it, and we
went on about the hearing.
And so I couldn't so
easily just push it aside.
We went home from
this Congress on high,
feeling optimistic that the FDA
was going to create a road map
and that someday very soon Elle
would have the bionic pancreas.
But we were also
living with the reality
that every day
was still so hard.
And at this stage, Elle
was entering puberty.
And when she was
first diagnosed,
you saw those photos, she
was 4 feet, 5 inches, and now
she's 5 feet 8 and 1/2 inches.
And all of that growing
affects diabetes management.
So puberty and hormones--
insulin is a hormone.
It's also hormone
resistant, so when
you're growing from 4 and
1/2 feet to 5 feet 8 inches
and you're becoming
a young woman,
that means your insulin
demands are being
tripled, in some instances.
And that roller coaster we
were right in the middle of.
And yet, we knew from
having been in Washington
that the reality of getting a
bionic pancreas was years away.
And we needed some more hope.
We needed something
else to look forward to.
And so I started digging,
and I started learning
about diabetes alert dogs.
And this is Coach.
Coach is Elle's
diabetes alert dog.
We are incredibly
lucky to have him.
What I discovered
when we first started
going through the
application process
is that the industry that
trains and provides service dogs
is not very well regulated.
And so I was finding
everything from the dogs cost
$10,000 to you have to
raise $25,000 to get a dog,
to the dog can do
anything you want it to.
It can bring you your slippers
and it can inject your insulin.
I mean, it got to the
point where I thought,
this is not going to work.
And then we found CARES.
CARES is an organization
that's based in Kansas.
They keep the cost
of their service dogs
very low because they partner
with a correctional facility
in Kansas.
And actually, since
we've written the book,
they've extended to two new
correctional facilities.
And they work with inmates
who meet certain criteria,
and they train those inmates
to do all the basic training
for the dogs.
And all that savings that they
realize by not having trainers
outside of the correctional
facility doing the training
gets passed along to families.
So when I started looking at
this, I thought, OK, well,
that seems fantastic.
What a great program.
It's an opportunity for people
in the correctional system
to get on the path
to work study.
It's an opportunity
for families like ours
to have a animal that
is much more affordable.
And it just seemed
for the first time
like maybe we could
give this a try.
They also, it was
very interesting--
CARES also said they so
believe in their training
that they would take the dog
back if you got the dog home
and it just didn't fit or
didn't work in your life--
if it didn't work.
And we thought, OK, well,
this is worth giving it a try.
And then of course the
wait list is 18 months,
because there aren't
enough trainers.
And Elle, as you
know, is one of four.
And our second daughter is
really the animal lover.
Elle had been bitten
by a dog as a child,
and so I often wondered,
would this work for her?
I would never describe
her before Coach
as an animal person.
And I worried that because
Coach would be working for Elle,
he might not be part
of our whole family.
And the rest, Anna, Caroline,
and William, our younger three
children, were
desperate for a dog,
and the idea of having
a dog come home and not
be able to be part of the
family just wouldn't work.
So fortunately, CARES
was willing to answer
all of my hundreds of
questions, and the answers
were all answers that seemed
like we could make work.
So we applied and we waited,
and every time the kids said,
we really want a dog, I
said, we have one coming.
Just a matter of when.
And we got a little more
time under our belt.
Elle moved her way
through middle school.
And around January
of 2013, we got
a phone call saying Coach is
going to be ready in March.
And honestly, before
that, I didn't really
think much about it.
I sort of-- I had an answer
for the kids every time
they asked for the
dog, and I still
had all this skepticism about
whether it would really work.
But there was reason enough to
hope that it was going to be OK
and it was worth a try.
And I didn't think much of it.
And then we got this phone
call and I'm thinking, oh,
are we really ready for this?
What's this going
to mean for Elle?
Elle's lived her whole life
out loud with diabetes,
but not being defined by it.
She would never describe
herself as a diabetic.
She would tell you
she's a theater kid
who is a phenomenal--
she loves school.
That's the part
I would tell you.
She's a phenomenal student.
And she happens
to have diabetes.
What's it going to
be like when she's
walking through the world
with a giant yellow dog
in a bright red vest, and
how will that affect her?
What is it going to
mean for our family?
Is this dog going to acclimate?
Can we afford him?
Will it really work?
And I was convinced it
wouldn't really work.
But he was really cute and we
would find a way to acclimate,
and maybe it would be a
beneficial part of our journey.
And then on a very snowy day
in March, Elle and my husband
Craig took a journey
to Kansas to get Coach.
He was ready at this point.
By the time they met
him for the first time,
he had had 2,000
hours of training.
He had been in the Ellsworth
Correctional Facility
for about a year of his life.
So the way CARES works is they
have puppies that get donated,
and the puppies
come from bloodlines
of dogs that have successfully
been service animals before.
And they go through
a screening process
and go to a foster family,
where, as puppies, they
get socialized and
they get housebroken.
And then when they get to be
about 3 and 1/2 or 4 months
they go into this
correctional facility
and they start working
with a trainer there.
And when the trainer
decides the dog has
hit all these basic
training milestones,
they then go back
to CARES, and CARES,
using scent detection--
so they take swabs
from the insides
of people's mouths
who are living with diabetes
when they're out of range,
so when they're experiencing a
low blood sugar or a high blood
sugar, and they train
the dog to alert
when they detect that scent.
And so all that advanced
training happens at CARES.
So by the time
Elle met Coach, he
had already been on
an airplane twice.
He had been living in
a correctional facility
for the first year of his life.
And when they met
that first time,
and I'll let her describe it
after, it was really magic.
And I was panicked at
home, because I was home
with our other three
children, and I
had a work obligation that
meant I couldn't travel
with Craig and Elle and had to
keep the other kids in school.
And being separated from
Elle is really difficult,
because I test her
blood sugars every night
in the middle of the night
at least twice, because we've
had situations where she's had
a seizure because of a low blood
sugar, and she's had
unexplained low blood sugars
in the middle of the night
that she doesn't wake up from.
So to have them be in Kansas
and to have me not be there,
even though my husband
knows how to do this,
was nerve wracking for me.
So I fell asleep the first night
they were away with my computer
open on my lap, and
I had sent Craig
a text saying,
please send me what
her number is when you check
her at 1:00 in the morning.
1:00 in the morning
came and went
and I don't get a response,
and I start to get panicked.
And then I text
him again and say,
why aren't you
responding to your text?
And then I call and I
can't get him to answer.
And we had had enough near
misses where I was almost
at the point where I was going
to call the lobby of the hotel
and ask them to go
knock on his door.
And of course he didn't
remember the time difference,
and so an hour later I get
this flurry of messages.
You're never going
to believe it,
but that first night in
the hotel room, Coach
knocked a backpack off
the table to wake them up
because Elle had
a low blood sugar.
And they're telling me this
through the phone and text
messages, and I'm
thinking that is absurd.
There's no way that works.
It's a small hotel room.
Maybe it was an accident.
It's a coincidence.
But Elle, in her voice when
I spoke to her the next day,
was absolutely sure that
he knew what he was doing,
that he knew her
blood sugar was low,
and that he was making
sure that somebody woke up
in order for her to treat it.
And that, of course, was before
they had any real training
together, so he didn't
have any signals that they
had worked out for
how he was going
to tell her when she was low.
And so the training continued.
They graduated, and as
a licensed service team,
they came home.
And I have to say,
this was the moment
I feared most, this idea
that she was going to now
be in the world with her
dog, and how was that
going to work for her socially?
And I remember getting the phone
call as they were preparing
to come home from Kansas
with Coach in tow,
knowing that he had graduated
and they had graduated
and they were a
licensed service team,
and he was going to be now
going to school with her.
And she said, mom, you
have to call the principal,
make sure they
know we're coming.
And I said, what do
you mean you're coming?
I thought he'll be at home and
he'll be with you at nighttime,
but you're not going
to bring him to school.
And she said, oh yeah, I'm
bringing him everywhere.
I'm bringing him to school and
I'm bringing him to dance class
and I'm bringing him to theater
rehearsal, and where I go,
he's going to go.
And I thought, OK, well,
she's comfortable with this,
but how is that
really going to work?
And what will that
be like for her?
Will she always be
the girl with the dog,
and how can she live with that?
And she doesn't
self-identify as a diabetic,
and how will she
explain all that?
And much to our
amazement and surprise,
I didn't need to answer
any of those questions,
because the love
between them and what
this relationship means to
her was all the explanation
that anybody needs.
And I share this
picture because, I mean,
literally this was during
a theater summer program
where she would leave
the house at 6:30
in the morning with Coach and
return at about 7:30 at night.
And where he goes, she goes.
And knowing that
they have each other
has created just an unbelievable
sense of relief for me.
To me, the most
unbelievable surprise
as I navigate and have tried
to figure out how this really
is going to work
long term for Elle
is that it has triangulated
our dynamic in such a way
that this is no longer
about diabetes, right?
She is empowered
as Coach's trainer
to reward him when he does
what he's supposed to do.
So instead of me
saying to her, when
did you last test
your blood sugar,
and you seem like
you might be high,
and did you take enough insulin
for that piece of pizza,
now it's a matter of, what
is Coach trying to tell me,
and how do I interpret what it
is he's telling me right now?
And when he does what
he's supposed to do,
I need to make
sure I reward him.
And diabetes isn't even
in the mix anymore.
It's about their relationship
and the bond they have,
and her role as his trainer.
And that's been a
gift that I never
could have imagined and
anticipated in all this.
And I have to say, I
share this because I
was so worried
about how it would
be with her at school with
him, and he's part of the team.
He has his own student ID.
He's the equivalent
of the school mascot.
As Elle says, he's
a friend magnet.
He's a conversation starter.
And he's allowed her to live
out loud with diabetes in a way
that we never could
have imagined,
while keeping her safe.
For me, as Elle's
mother anticipating
the start of college-- we
started visiting schools
this past month-- and when she
was first diagnosed, and night
after night I'd be lying awake
waiting to test her blood
sugar at 1:00 in the
morning, thinking,
how are we ever
going to do this?
How is she going to live
independently and have
the life she's intended to
have with the risks that come
every day with type I diabetes?
And now to know she's got Coach
by her side, who's helping her
every day, just provides
the kind of reassurance
I never imagined we could have.
And I have to give you just
a couple recent stories
about Coach's alerting.
A couple weeks ago, Elle was
experiencing a low blood sugar
and she was late getting
to school, getting
to class, her English class.
And he had been
trying to alert her,
and she was a
little disoriented,
because that's what often
happens when you're low.
And he was trying
to get her attention
and pulling on the
leash, and she's trying
to pull him into the classroom.
And they walk by the nurse's
office, and he stops.
And he takes his leash and
he pulls back on his leash
and tries to pull her
into the nurse's office
to get her to test
her blood sugar.
And sure enough, her
blood sugar was 65.
So my joke to her is, why do
you make him work so hard?
But ultimately, those kinds
of things happen every day.
People often say, how
often does he alert you?
And because he's trained to
alert when her blood sugar is
below 80 or above 200, he alerts
her two or three times a day,
at least.
If he can't get her to wake
up in the middle of the night
because her blood sugar is
low, he comes and finds me.
And that was really the moment
when I stopped being skeptical
and started trusting him.
It was about two weeks or so in
after he and Elle had come home
from Kansas, and it was
about 4:00 in the morning,
and I'm not trusting him
yet so I'm still getting up
the middle of the night
and I'm testing her blood
sugar at 1:00 in the morning.
And she was in range
at 1:00 in the morning,
and I went off to bed.
And at 4:00 in the morning
I feel this wet something
on my cheek.
And I was disoriented, and
I'm still not used to the fact
that we have a
Coach in the house.
And so I sort of pushed
him off and said,
it's all right, Coach.
And he then put both paws on
the bed and right on top of me.
And so I, disoriented, and
I got up and I thought,
well this can't-- I mean,
I just tested her at 1:00.
She was fine, and
maybe he has to go out.
So he wanted me to follow
him up to her bedroom,
so up I went and
tested her blood sugar,
and sure enough,
she was low again.
And those things
happen often when
you're living with diabetes,
with no explanation.
And to know that she's got him
and that I have him by her side
has just been an
incredible sense of relief.
So the clan is clearly very
happy to have Coach in the mix.
As Elle has said from
the very beginning,
bringing Coach home
was the first time
she felt like diabetes was
actually giving something back
to our whole family.
This was us celebrating his
fourth birthday in October.
And as you can see, Anna,
Caroline, and William
think the sun rises
and sets over Coach.
And we are very proud
to be here this week,
because our book just came
out in paperback on Tuesday,
so it's been a very fun journey
to get out and share our story.
We've been able to help
other families find
their way to CARES,
and we've now got,
because we've been sharing
the story for a while,
we've got families who now have
their own dogs, which has just
been incredibly gratifying.
And actually, CNN just aired
a piece about our story,
and they went into
the prison and got
to talk to the inmates
who do the training, which
was a gift for me,
because I had not
been able to be part of that
since Elle and Craig were
the ones in Kansas.
And to hear the
inmates describe what
it was like to read the story
and hear how our lives were so
positively impacted by what they
have been able to do for us,
it's just been an amazing gift.
So we feel very fortunate.
And with that I'd love to
open it up to questions.
And Elle's here and happy
to answer questions, too.
AUDIENCE: So this is
a question for Elle.
You're about to go
to college, or you're
looking into colleges.
What are you looking forward to?
What sorts of plans excite you?
ELLE: I have no idea yet.
I'm still looking at
schools and figuring out
different programs.
We just started-- we
just visited Emerson
and Boston Conservatory.
And I found out last week that
I got into Carnegie Mellon's
musical theater summer program.
AUDIENCE: Congratulations.
ELLE: Thank you.
So I'm really
excited about that.
And Coach will be going with me.
STEFANY SHAHEEN:
Which, for-- that's
a six-week overnight
program, which
will be the first time she's
ever been away from home
for that period of time.
And I should say that
the combination of Coach
and a continuous
glucose monitor,
which I can now see
on my phone, make
me feel very reassured that this
is going to be a good thing.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
had another question.
So when you mentioned the
training, the people who
actually train them
in the prisons,
is there a way for the families
to actually write to them?
I mean, I had an
ACL transplant, so I
was able to write the
donors anonymously,
but that felt really
an important act to do.
Do they have a way of
your being able to--
STEFANY SHAHEEN:
Unfortunately not.
They're not allowed
to maintain contact
with the families of the people.
AUDIENCE: But let's say,
anonymous, because for example,
the donor's family have
no idea who I am, but--
STEFANY SHAHEEN: Yes, yes.
We can write to
them, but they're not
allowed to write to us.
AUDIENCE: OK.
STEFANY SHAHEEN: So they're
not allowed to reach us.
AUDIENCE: But they
do get the feedback.
STEFANY SHAHEEN:
Yes, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
STEFANY SHAHEEN:
And in fact, you
want to share the
interaction with Michael?
ELLE: Sure.
When I was in Kansas
getting Coach with my dad,
we actually spent a
few hours in the prison
where our dogs were trained.
And we walked into the
room, and all the inmates
were sitting there with the
dogs that they were currently
training at the
time, and they all
started tearing up
because they were getting
so emotional over
seeing these dogs
and seeing them with the people
that they would be helping.
And I got to meet one
of the two trainers
that got to train Coach.
And I was a little
nervous at first,
because it was a little
intimidating, 'cause
he was a very, very large man.
But he was so sweet,
and got really touched
that Coach was helping
someone like me
and that he could be a part
of an organization like CARES.
AUDIENCE: One of my daughters
has been, over the last six
months, training service dogs.
She's between being a graduate
student in animal behavior
and going to vet school, and
so this is very interesting.
I'm not a dog person.
I have had contact with a
whole series of these dogs
over these last six months.
They're amazing.
But the process
of training them,
so this is what
she's been doing--
can you say more about how--
that particular program is one.
Is there is an infrastructure or
a pipeline for dogs like this,
and to what extent do they need
to be specialized early on?
It sounded like Coach had sort
of a service dog background
and then was trained in
particular skills that
are valuable here.
Say more about the training,
because it's a huge project.
STEFANY SHAHEEN: Sure.
We actually had the
privilege of meeting
the person who developed the
training protocol for diabetes
alert dogs.
He himself was a dog trainer
for search and rescue
and narcotic detection, and
he was also living with type
I diabetes.
And what he discovered was
that the dogs could pick up
on the scent when
he was low or high,
and so he developed a
protocol that is used now
and was used to train Coach.
The pipeline-- part of why
we wanted to share our story
was that the single
biggest barrier
to getting more
dogs more affordably
available to families is the
availability of trainers.
So there are-- the puppies
are not the problem.
It's the number of trainers
who are able to train.
And the way that
CARES works, they
don't breed dogs and
let the puppies wait.
They breed the
dogs and the timing
of the puppies being
born coincides with when
a trainer is available.
So as soon as the puppy's born,
they are studied and evaluated
to see, are these
dogs going to be
ready to do what
they need to do?
So some dogs don't mate
it through the training.
In fact, we were
joking that we want
to be on the list
for the dropout dogs,
because when Elle and
Coach go to college,
we're going to need
another dog in the house.
And there are PTSD,
seizure detection, diabetes
alert-- CARES doesn't do
this, but there are also
dogs now being trained
in cancer detection.
And so what CARES
would explain is
that based on what they
see the dog's abilities,
they would be either funneled
into diabetes alert or seizure
detection or PTSD.
They also are particular
about which breeds
get trained for what.
So often you're talking about
German shepherds for veterans,
especially, who are
getting dogs for PTSD,
and that's because
the breed is such
that they're more
intimidating, and their job
is to protect the perimeter of
a veteran or somebody coping
with PTSD.
And in fact, there were
multiple veterans in Elle class
who were there for a
dog to help treat PTSD.
They use labs and
golden retrievers
predominantly for seizure
detection and diabetes alert,
especially in young
people, because they're
in situations where the dogs
have to be especially social.
And they say it's
about 2,000 hours,
but Elle works with
Coach every day
in order to help
him be successful.
Do you want to share
like the kinds of things
you do every day?
ELLE: He needs to
stay very regimented,
so he stays on a very specific
schedule in terms of feeding
and when I walk him
and stuff like that.
But I also have to
groom him once a week.
And I take him on
training walks just
to make sure that
he is up to date
and still alert at
all times of the day.
STEFANY SHAHEEN: We had
an interesting dilemma.
That summer where I showed
you that photo where
they were both
asleep in the car,
he was having trouble waking
up in the middle of the night.
And there were a couple times
where she was just below range
when he should have been awake
and alerting, and he wasn't.
And I called the
trainer and I said,
I don't know what's happening.
And she said, well, describe
what the day is like.
I said, well, they
leave the house at 6:30
and they're in this
summer program all day,
and then he's getting
home at 7:30 at night
and we take him for his walk.
And she said, he's exhausted.
He's working overtime
and he needs a break.
So we have to build in
specified sleep time
where he can sleep
and know she's OK
and he's sort of off
the clock, not working.
We also often get the
question about play.
Can he ever just be a dog,
or is he always working?
And what we've learned is that
you have to distinguish play
as a reward.
So he gets to play when he's
done what he's supposed to do.
And then you distinguish
play from work
by taking the vest off,
taking the working collar off
and putting the play collar on.
So you'll often see
him outside, if he's
being rewarded with fetch
or some kind of play,
he doesn't have his vest on.
He's got his play collar on.
But he also is
really wired to work.
So whenever they're
separated for any reason,
he's very unsettled, because
he is looking for a job to do.
I remember the very first
time they were separated,
she went to the
mall with friends
and there was not room
in the car for Coach.
And they'd been together
nonstop for four weeks.
And the trainer
said, they're going
to have to get comfortable not
being together all the time,
because inevitably
there will be times
when they're not together.
So she left the house crying.
As she's leaving, his nose
is pressed against the glass,
and then he was very agitated.
And she said, well, he's
was looking for a job to do.
Give him a job to do.
So we put the laundry basket
in the middle of the kitchen
floor, and he would walk
around the kids' bedrooms,
pick up the stuffed animals,
put them in the laundry basket,
get a reward.
So he is very much
a working dog.
He needs to work, and he
needs to stay regimented.
He goes to the
bathroom on command.
People often say,
how do you know
if he's alerting versus
just trying to tell you
he needs to go out?
He doesn't tell you he needs
to go out, because he goes out
when he is supposed
to go out, and he
goes to the bathroom on
command, and not otherwise.
Yeah, it's amazing.
AUDIENCE: And early
on, you mentioned
when you were first
investigating service dogs,
that it was-- you were surprised
at how unregulated it was.
Now, in retrospect, do you think
that there's a need for more?
Would that be helpful?
What's your sense of
what could be done
that would be useful there?
STEFANY SHAHEEN: Yeah, I
have to say diabetes alert
dogs are still very unusual.
There aren't that many.
CARES, which has been in
operation for 10 years,
has only trained 1,300
dogs total, and not
just for diabetes alert.
It's a new and emerging area.
And I think we need
better research that
actually demonstrates the effect
these animals can have, not
just from a
biometric standpoint,
because actually, Elle's
A1C is better now than it
was before we had Coach.
So we could tell you that she
actually is in range more often
and her body is healthier
than it was without him.
But we need that quantified
in the form of research that's
not just anecdotal.
But beyond that, I
think the industry
itself is very poorly regulated.
We've met too many families who
have spent an inordinate amount
of money, I mean tens
of thousands of dollars,
have raised money through
philanthropic efforts
to get a dog, and the dog
comes and doesn't work.
So there needs to be a
national accreditation
process that is the standard.
CARES works with one and
abides by it very carefully,
but there are others that don't.
And ultimately, right
now, Coach and Elle
are protected through
the ADA, because they're
a trained service team and
he has a demonstrated job.
But how many of you have been on
an airplane with a service dog,
right?
So there's also this--
it's a very gray area,
and we need to tighten
it up, because it
will help the people who really
are in need of a service dog,
and it will help
the families who
are trying to navigate their
way through this process
and have some assurance.
I mean, CARES has said to
me, they hear from families
all the time who spent $25,000
and got a dog that didn't work.
And that's just not right.
AUDIENCE: This is a
question for Elle.
Since you started at
school, how have you
found that the school
environment, or maybe even just
the way your friends think
about these types of issues
have changed, because
you've been living with it,
but have you seen changes
come about in your school,
or your friends are more
interested in talking
about medical research?
ELLE: Not necessarily.
He-- like my mom said before,
I don't really classify myself
as a diabetic, so
it's not something
I talk about very often.
It's just sort of a
part of my daily life.
So when I got Coach,
especially as a freshman going
into this very large
school and trying
to navigate social aspects of
high school, that was hard,
because I was-- I
felt at the beginning,
before I even got Coach, that he
might be putting a label on me,
or just a label that something
might be wrong with me.
But then I got to school,
and they loved him.
He really became a part
of the school community,
and everyone welcomed
him with open arms.
My freshman English class,
they had tennis balls
on the bottom of our
chairs, and he would always
try to bite them off.
So the next day,
my English teacher
brought in a bucket
of old tennis balls
for him to chew on during class.
STEFANY SHAHEEN:
Which she wasn't
supposed to do, by the way.
ELLE: It was a reward.
STEFANY SHAHEEN: I know.
ELLE: But he's really become a
part of the school community.
But in terms of diabetes
being a conversation topic,
I don't think that
has changed as much.
But I'm willing to talk
about it with anyone
who has questions about it.
STEFANY SHAHEEN: What
we have discovered
is that without Coach, the
topic of diabetes is very heavy,
because you're trying to
explain the reality of what it's
like to live with
a chronic disease,
and what it means that you
can't go to sleep and trust
that you're safe
through the night.
But with Coach, it allows us to
have conversations with people
who are really fascinated
by how Coach works
and what he does for Elle, that
open the door to information
and education about what it's
like to live with diabetes.
And I think that's
been very empowering.
And part of the reason
we share the story,
we really wrestled with, do
we want to write this book?
Do we really want
to tell the story?
And I remember a
conversation Elle
and I had, because I felt like
it was up to her to decide.
I was willing to do the work if
she was willing to put herself
out there.
And you answer so many
questions about, well,
is it what you ate that
caused your diabetes?
Is it because you
didn't exercise enough,
the confusion between type II
diabetes and type I diabetes,
and lots of people who have
asked her if she's just
training Coach, or
wave their hands
in front of her face
to see if she needs--
if he's a seeing-eye dog.
So for all those reasons, she
wanted to share the story.
And I think it's been very
empowering in that way,
because it allows us to open
up about life before Coach
and the risks that Elle lives
with every day with Coach
in a way that I think
without him is a much
harder conversation to have.
So that's been wonderful.
AUDIENCE: And then just one
quick follow up-- how has he
taken to music and theater?
Does he have any
kind of-- express
any preference or, he just
has to wait quietly backstage?
ELLE: He loves it.
He likes it more-- my younger
sister plays volleyball
and my brother plays
baseball and soccer.
And he hates the
noises at the game.
But he loves coming
to rehearsal.
And within a year
of me getting him,
I was doing a summer
program, and they actually
wrote a part for
him in the show,
and he had his own little
dressing room backstage.
It was really cute.
STEFANY SHAHEEN: And they
were both in "Of Mice and Men"
with Boston Children's
Theater down here,
and that was the worst
for me, because they
both got killed in the play.
I said, OK, no more.
Coach and Elle can't
have something bad
happen in the play.
But it's been amazing.
And as Elle said, I think he
must have had whistle training
at some point, because he
cannot handle-- I mean,
he just does not like being in
the gym cheering on Anna with
the referee whistles.
It drives him crazy.
We actually had,
and I'll share this,
this is a very present
and pressing story for me.
Elle just opened a
show a few weeks ago,
and we hadn't figured out how
to handle performance nights
with Coach, because there's no
way to keep him safe backstage
and allow him to do his
job, because he would have
to be crated, and then he'd
have to bark in order to alert,
and so he'd be
barking in the show.
And we've tried a
few different things,
and it just doesn't work.
So opening night, she was
running the show in rehearsal
before the actual opening, and
didn't have a Coach with her,
had had too much insulin for the
amount of dancing and activity
she was doing in the
show and not enough food
before the show with nerves,
and her continuous glucose
monitor was alarming
her on her phone,
but she couldn't
hear it because she
was on the stage with
the music playing.
Luckily, it was alarming
me on my phone at work,
and I was incessantly
trying to reach her,
couldn't reach her because
she's on the stage,
was able to find someone
in the box office
to go into the theater to
pull her off the stage,
and it took us about two
hours of treating the low
to get her into a healthy
range so she could perform.
And I use that as an
example because it just
happened a few weeks ago, and
the juxtaposition of what that
would have looked
like with Coach--
so if that had happened
in a rehearsal and Coach
was in the theater
in rehearsal, he just
would have walked onto the
stage and made her stop,
and made her very aware
of what was happening.
And that's the value
of having him around,
why we feel so lucky.
One more question, anyone?
Well, this has been such a gift.
I can't thank you enough for
the chance to share our story,
and we look forward to
coming back at a later time.
[APPLAUSE]